البرلمان العراقي يبحث وامنى اقليم
كردستان وعرفنا امريكي لاي عمل عسكريا
ينتهي كؤوس سياده العراق واستقرار سوريا
ضد المتظاهرين وهجوم بالزجاجات الحارقه
على مقر للنسيج فيزا
طالب
[موسيقى]
اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى نشره الاخبار من
العربيه من المقرره ان يناقش البرلمان
العراقي اليوم ملف حفظ سياده البلاد بعد
سلسله من الهجمات الايرانيه والتركيه
المتكرره على اقليم كردستان العراق وقال
البرلمان الاتحادي ان الجلسه تكون مغلقه
وسبق ان عقد البرلمان العراقي جلسات
الممثله طيله السنوات الماضيه وكثيرا ما
كانت تنتهي بالادانه او تشكيل لجانا
للتحقيق وتقص الحقائق
دعت الخارجيه طول امريكيه في بيان الى خفض
التسعيدي في سوريا وقالت ان الولايات
المتحده تعارض اي عمل عسكري يذاع واستقرار
الوضع هناك في اشاره الى العمليه العسكريه
التركيه الاخيره كما ابدت الخارجيه
الامريكيه معارضتها لاي عمل عسكري ينتهي
كو سياده العراق من خلال اعمال عسكريه غير
منسقه مع الحكومه العراقيه
المبعوث الاممي الخاص الى سوريا
بدرسون طالبه جميع الاطراف
بالالتزام بكافه اتفاقاته وقف اطلاق النار
واحترامي سياده البلاد ووحده اراضيها ونقل
مكتب المبعوث الامميه عن بذرسون قوله انه
سينخلط مع جميع الاطراف في محادثات بصيغه
استانه والتي ستنعقد اليوم وغدا واضاف
المبعوث الاممي انه سيحض جميع الاطراف على
احتواء الموقف في سوريا وحمايه المدنيين
ووقف التصعيد والتركيز على العمليه
العسكريه
وزير الدفاع التركيه خلاص يا كارا اكد من
جانبه ان القوات قوات بلاده حيضتها 184
شخصا وصفهم بالارهابيين منذ انطلاق عمليه
المخلب السيف بدعم بري وجويا من شمال
سوريا وفي شمال سوريا والعراق
في منطقه اسطنبول سنجعلهم يدفعون ثمن كل
الجرائم التي ارتكبوها اليوم وما قبلها
وفقا لاخر المعلومات التي تلقيناها وفي
اعقاب غارتنا الجويه المدعومه باسلحه
الارضيه تم تحيدوهم 148 مسلحا
صرخاتهن صوت للالم الم لفقدان 12 شخصا
قتلتهم تركيا في غارات جويه على الاكراد
ليله السبت المنصرم
يسود التوتر كل الجبهات من ديرك الى منبج
على طول الشريط الحدودي الذي تسيطر عليه
قصد وقصف مدفعي يطال مواقع مدنيه
تنتهي بنتائجها هنا بمزيد من من يفارقون
احبتهم وذويهم مدنيون وعسكريون وصحفيون
قتلوا في ضربات التركيه الاخيره
ماذا فعلنا لهم لم يهاجمهم ولم نسرق
اموالهم لماذا يهاجموننا نحن على ارضنا
وفي وطننا لذلك لا نعرف اي تفسير لصمت
الدول الكبرى
[موسيقى]
تخطن شعبي رافقه تهديد جسد بالرد على
الغارات التركيه في الوقت المناسب وربما
تكون العمليتان العسكريتان في كل تركيا
وقرقميش بدايته بين حلم الاكراد في رؤيه
كردستانهم الموعوده وعمليات تركيا
المستمره لاجهاضه تبقى هذه البقعه من
الارض ساحه مفتوحه للقتل والقتال مع غياب
اي افقي لحلول سياسيه او عسكريه تنهي هذا
الصراع من مدينه ديرك شمال شرق سوريا
جماعه كاش العربيه
هل تقع مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جاكسو لبنان مع رئيس هيئه الاركان
الاسرائيليه في كوخافي الذي يزور واشنطن
واشدد خلال اللقاء على دعم الاداره
الامريكيه الصارم للامن اسرائيل
المتحدثته باسم مجلس الامن القومي ادريان
واتسون قارت في بيان ان سوليفان اكد ايضا
التزام الرئيس الامريكي
كما اكد الجانبان عزمهم المشترك على
معالجه التحديات التحديات الامنيه التي
تؤثر على الشرق الاوسط بما في ذلك تهديدات
التي تشكلها ايران واوكلاها الجانبان بحث
ايضا اهميه اتخاذ خطوات لتهدئه الوضع
الامني في الضفه الغربيه
ان حل الدولتين يظل افضل وسيله لتحقيق
سلامه
افاد سنه الديمقراطيه بوب مارندز رئيسها
لجنه مجلس الشيوخ لشؤون الخارجيه بان هناك
تقارير مروعه جديده تفيد بحمله العنف التي
يشنها النظام الايراني ضد المتظاهرين في
مدينه مع بدر الكرديه وقال السيناتور
الديمقراطيه النيران تنشر نفس التكتيكات
الوحشيه ضد المدنيين الابرياء كما فعلت في
سوريا
من جانبه اعلن البرلمان الاوروبي واقفه اي
اتصال مباشر بين اعضائه ونظائهم
الايرانيين حتى اشعار اخر وقالت رئيسه
البرلمان الاوروبيه روبوتا ميتسولا في
بيان ان القرار ياتي ردا على عقوبه فرضتها
طهران ضد كيانات وشخصيات اوروبيه الشهر
الماضي
السلطات الايرانيه على التوقف فورا عن
اصدار احكام الاعدام على محتجنا معتقلين
في البلاد
[موسيقى]
واخبار طعمي ده
وفي الدخل الايراني اعلنها قائد قوى الامن
الداخلي في محافظه سيستان وبلوشستان جنوب
شرقي ايران محمد خنبري اعلن عن مقتل شرطي
في اطلاق نار بمدينه زاهدان ونقلت وكاله
ايرنا عن قنبري قوله ان مجموعه من
المسلحين يستقلون سيارتا اطلق النار
باتجاه دوريات شرطه في جازان واضف ان
المسلحين هادوا بالفرار ثوره تنفيذ الهجوم
الذي اسفر ايضا عن اصابه ضابط من شرطه
زاهده
السادسه عشره من سبتمبر الماضي بدا نقطه
تتحول في ايران القصه بدات بضربه قاتله
تلقاها راس الفتاه العشرينيات الكرديه
الايرانيه مهسا اميني داخل مركز شرطه
الاخلاق في العاصمه طهران اثرات قالها
بحجه عدم ارتدائها الحجاب الكامل في اليوم
التالي وبعد الاعلان عن وفاه امين خرجت
احتجاجات شعبيه عفويه في مسقط راسها
لتنتقل الى سائر المدن الكرديه بعد ذلك
انطفت عشرات المدن الايرانيه الكبيره في
مختلف المحافظات وخرج الالف من اصفهان في
الوسط الى مشهد في الشمال الشرقي مرورا
بالشراز جنوبا ورشت في الشمال وفي محافظه
بلوشستان خرج الاهالي الى الشوارع وواجههم
الامن بالرصاص الحي ما اسفر عن ما يقارب
90 قتيلا من البلوش
النساء والفتيات التي حملت الاحتجاجات
وشعارا ينصب على مطالبهن اولا النساء
الحياه الحريه يشاركنا بقوه في تلك
الاحتجاجات مئات الطلاب في اكثر من 142
جامعه دفعوا خارج بواباتها واغلقت المحل
تجاريه مرارا ابوابها للتضامن مع
المحتاجين بالاضافه الى مشاركه اطباء
ومخرجين وفنانين ورياضيين واعلاميين منهم
من شارك على الارض واخرون الحاذ بمواقفهم
علنا الى جانب شعبهم في العشرين من نوفمبر
الجاري تجددت الاحتجاجات في المدن الكرديه
غربي ايران ونقلت السلطات وحدات الحرس
الثوري الايراني والقوات الخاصه الى مدينه
مع بادي الكرديه في اذربيجان الغربيه وبعد
يوم واحد على قدمينها بعد خرجت تظاهرات
حاشده شهدتها مدينه تاجوان رود وبيران شهر
الكرديتان غربي ايران
ردا لطعمه على المحتاجين باطلاق النار
بشكل مباشر وعبر القناصه وشاهدت مدينه
بوشهر هي الاخرى التي تقع جنوبيه ايران
على الخليج مظاهره الحاشده امام مقر
المحافظه وردت قوات الامن على المحتاجين
بالقاء الغازي المسيلي للدموع حنان المصري
العربيه
التي تفيد بان المملكه تناقش زياده انتاج
النفط
حياكم الله حضر الرئيس
في الدول الاعضاء في حلف شمال الاطلسيه
على ضمان حمايه المحطات النوويه
الاوكرانيه
واورو اوروبا
الاماكن النوويه الاوكرانيه ولهذا فان نزع
السلاح من محطه
الاهميه
الطاقه اشكر الرئيس
المنشات النوويه كما اننا نبذل قصار جهدنا
لعقد مؤتمر حول اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا
حيث ابدى فرنسا استع لاظهار زمام المبادره
بشكل مؤثر وفعال
السعاده وكان يا سيطره الكاميرا على
خيرسون بجنوب البلاد قد ايه يقلب التوازن
باكمله لصالح موسكو في خيرسون او جنوبا
شرقا هذا تفاصيل في التقرير التاليه
سلسله انتصارات اوكرانيا قد تتجه الى نقطه
انعطاف اخرى
فبالرغم من استعادتها مدينه خيرس بالكامل
بعد قتال عنيف الا انها قد تضع نفسها في
مرمى النيران بسبب تعريض امدادات القرم
للخطر وفقا للمعلومات التي ذكرتها والسرير
جورنال كما ان القوات الروسيه سحبت ما يصل
الى 20,000 فردي من قوات النخبه بامان في
خطوه منها لاعاده الانتشار ونقلها الى جهه
اخرى بالقرب من مدينه خرسون للتحضر لمعركه
اخرى وفي المقابل العسكريون الاوكرانيون
يرون ان المعركه الصعبه ستكون خارج صفاته
وهي مدينه على اطراف خرسون والتي توجد
فيها نخبه من القوات الخاصه الروسيه تختلط
بالقوات التي تم التعبئتها حديثا بحسب
واشنطن بولس كما ان هؤلاء الجنود تدعمهم
طائرات استطلاع بدون طيار الاستهداف
القوات الاوكرانيه التي تحاول التقدم
زياده اعداد القوات الروسيه في خرسون
جنوبا ودوم باز شرقا قد يحد من قدرتها على
الهجوم في مواقع اخرى
كما ان هذا التقدم الاخير للقوات
الاوكرانيه قد يمكنها من استهداف خطوط
الامداد الروسيه التي تصل الى شبه جزيره
القرم التي ضمتها روسيا في عام 2014 خطوط
الامداد هذه تشكل اهميه قصوى لروسيا خصوصا
وان قواعدها العسكريه في شبه جزيره القرم
يعتمدون على الامدادات والمياه العذبه من
البر الرئيس الاوكراني التي تمر عبر
الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها الان
وبسبب هذه الاهميه قامت روسيا بالاستعداد
مسبقا في حاله حدوث في اي اختراق من
القوات الاوكرانيه
وذلك من خلال حفل خنادق بالقرب من حدود
شبه جزيره القرم ودمباس اي على بعد 40
ميلا تقريبا خلف الخطوط الاماميه بحسب
تقرير نشرته وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
لصحيفه جورنال بالاضافه الى هذا الموقع
المهم الذي تستهدفه القوات الاوكرانيه
فهناك الجسر البري الذي يمتد غربا من
روسيا الى ديني برو والذي تحاول كيف من
خلاله قطعه هذا الرابط الروسي الحيوي من
خلال التركيز على فك الحصار عن زموريج
المحاصره التي من شانها ان تقطع السبل
بالقوات الروسيه الى الغرب
وتعزل القوات في شبه جزيره القرم سلطان
العربيه
نفى وزير الطاقه السعوديه لامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان نافع بشكل انقطع التقرير
التي تفيد بان المملكه تناقش زياده انتاج
النفط بمقدار 500000 برميل يوميا واكد
الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان ان خفض
الانتاج الحليب بمقدار مليوني برميل يوميا
مستمر حتى نهايه عام 2023 وقال وزير
الطاقه السعوديه انه من المعروف انه بيك
بلاس لا تبحث اي قرارات قبل اجتماعاتها
واشار الى الاستعداد للتدخل واتخاذ
اجراءات اخرى لخفض الانتاج للموازنه بين
العرض والطلب عند الحاجه
اعلن المجلس العسكري في مالي حظر انشطه كل
المنظمات غير الحكوميه التي تملها او
تدعمها فرنسا في مالي ومن بينها تلك التي
تعمل في مجال في المجال الانساني رئيس
الوزراء الانتقاليه على الكولونيل عبد
الله ميجا هذا القرار الى اعلان باريس
اخيرا تعليقا مساعداتها العامه للتنميه في
مالي بعد ثلاثه اشهر على استكمال سحب
قواتها من البلاد على خلفيه مزاعم
باستعانه باماكو بمقاتلين من مجموعه من
مجموعه الروسيه
ندى اعضاء في مجلس الامن الدولي باطلاق
كوريا الشماليه صاروخا باليستيا يوم امس
من دوني اصدار بيان الرسمي بسبب معارضه
الصين وروسيا وافقي ما افاد دبلوماسيون
وجاء في البيان ان اطلق كوريا الشماليه
للصواريخ يشكل تصعيدا خطيرا وتهديدا واضحا
للسلم والامن الدولي
من العقاب نتيجه عدم تحرك مجلس الامن حياه
لتجاربها الصاروخيه
البرلمان العراقي يبحث عن اقليم كردستان
وعرفنا امريكي لاي عمل عسكريا ينتهي كوسيا
ذات العراق واستقرار سوريا
واشنطن تتهم ايران بالسلوك الوحشي ضد
المتظاهرين وهجوم بالزجاجات الحارقه على
مقر للباسيج في زهدان
زين الاسكي يطالبنيته بحمايه المنشات
النوويه ونزع السلاح من محطه
شكرا لكم لطيب المتابعه القاكم بعد دقائق
[موسيقى]